hello and welcome as you probably know
deep learning has already transformed
traditional internet businesses like web
search and advertising but deep learning
is also enabling brand new products and
businesses and ways of helping people to
recreate it everything ranging from
better healthcare where do blogging is
getting really good at reading x-ray
images to delivering personalized
education to precision agriculture to
even self-driving cars and many others
if you want to learn the tools of deep
learning and Gabel to apply them to
build these amazing things I want to
help you get there
when you finish the sequence of courses
on Coursera called a specialization you
will be able to put deep learning onto
your resume with confidence over the
next decade I think all of us have an
opportunity to build an amazing world
amazing society that is AI powered and I
hope that you will play a big role in
the creation of this AI power society so
that let's get started I think that AI
is the new electricity starting about a
hundred years ago the electrification of
our society transformed every major
industry every imaging from translations
when factoring to healthcare
expectations and many more and I think
that today we see a surprisingly clear
power for AI to bring about an equally
big transformation and of course the
part of AI that is rising rapidly and
driving a lot of these developments is
deep learning so today
deep learning is one of the most highly
sought after skills in the technology
world and through this course and a few
courses after this one I want to help
you to gain and master those skills so
just what you learn in this sequence of
causes also called a specialization on
Coursera in the first course you learn
about the foundations of neural networks
to learn about neural networks and deep
learning this video that you're watching
is part of this first course which lasts
four weeks in total and each of the five
causes in this specialization will be
about two to four weeks work both of
them actually shorter than four weeks
but
this first cause you learn how to build
a new network including a deep neural
network and how to train it on data and
at the end of this course you'll be able
to build a deep neural network to
recognize yes what caps for some reason
there is a cat meme running around in
deep learning and so following tradition
in this first course we'll build a cat
recognizer then in the second course
you'll learn about the practical aspects
of deep learning so you'll learn
now that you've built in your network
how to actually get it to perform well
to learn about hyper constituting
regularization how to diagnose lies and
variants and advanced optimization
algorithms like momentum rmsprop and the
atom optimization algorithm sometimes it
seems like there's a lot of tuning even
some black magic and how you build in
your network so the second course which
is just three weeks will demystify some
of that black magic in a third course
which is just two weeks you learn how to
structure your machine learning project
it turns out that the strategy for
building a machine learning system has
changed in the area of deep learning so
for example the way you fit your data
into train development or depth also
called holdout cross validation set and
test sets has changed in the error of
deep learning so what are the new best
practices for doing graph and whatever
your training set and your test set come
from different distributions that's
happening a lot more in the area of deep
learning so how do you deal with that
and if you've heard of end-to-end deep
learning you also learn more about that
in this third course and see when you
should use it and maybe when you
shouldn't the material in this third
course is relatively unique I'm going to
share with you a lot of the hot one
lessons that I've learned building and
shipping quite a lot of deep learning
products this as I know this is
longevity Rho that is not taught in most
universities that active learning causes
but I think I really help you to get
your deep learning systems to work well
in the next course will then talk about
convolutional neural networks often
abbreviated see
convolutional net works or convolutional
neural networks are often applied to
images so you learn how to build these
models in course for finally in course 5
you learn sequence models and how to
apply them to natural language
processing and other problems so
sequence models includes models like
recurrent neural networks abbreviate RNs
and OST n models sensor long short-term
memory models you learn what these terms
mean equals 5 and be able to apply them
to natural language processing problems
so you learn these models in closed 5
and be able to apply them to sequence
data so for example natural language is
just a sequence of words and you also
understand how these models can be
applied to speech recognition or to
music generation and other problems so
through these causes you learn the tools
of deep learning you'll be able to apply
them to build amazing things and I hope
many of you through this will also be
able to advance your career so that
let's get started please go into the
next video we will talk about deep
learning applied to supervised learning